hi i'm here with Kasich who is one of
the cofounders of locket and costs
should I like to talk to you a little
bit about how you iterate quickly and
how do you do user testing to make sure
that you have a good product oh sure so
once we come up with the product feature
or something which we want to build and
like try testing it out on a large user
base we quickly list out all the action
items and then we talked to all the
people who are very close to us and see
what their feedback is and then we
iteratively build on top of it we start
off from a very very small product I
mean like feature addition to our
current app or we build a very small MVP
and then we test it across different
users get their feedback try to track
their metrics and see if it is going in
the positive direction or know if it is
going in the positive direction then we
take it up improve it or we remove all
the features which are not doing good
and that way we I delayed a couple of
times to get to a place where we can
release and test it out yeah and you
touch a little bit about how you'll
contact move your friends or people in
your network are there any other
specific users that you'll make sure to
let go after to make sure you're any
different demographics or maybe
particular people who have certain
phones or you know well it totally
depends on the kind of the application
for example if we are releasing an
application for students then we mainly
look at the kind of phones they are
using and the main like what kind of
apps they are already using and based on
their like interest for the UI as well
as based on their utilization ways we
come up with the features and organize
it in such a way that it will appeal to
them and we also make sure that the UI
is a way animated and very focused to
that particular demographic for example
if we are targeting mid forties or
something we don't really need to make
it very colorful and very animated but
if we are talking to someone at 14 or 15
then we want to keep it very engaging
and like really interesting so beast
based on all these features we come up
with lists of things which we like try
to get people into the workplace and see
how they use it and like how they can
respond to that and from there on build
on top of